welcome to episode 33 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with dr sean
baker
dr shawn baker was the first major
carnivore doctor on the scene and holds
a special place
in my heart about five days into me only
eating beef
i was feeling quite ill and quite insane
and terrified i was also breastfeeding
my daughter at the time and i was really
desperate to get my arthritis and my
mood
under control about five days into the
diet i didn't know anybody else did an
all beef diet five days in i gave up and
i had
lettuce of all things uh the next day my
arthritis and my mood had dipped
significantly i was itchy everywhere and
freaking out and my friend owen sent me
dr sean baker
on joe rogan and i watched the episode
and after listening to him talk about
how he had only eaten beef for a number
of years
and was doing great i felt so much
relief and i felt so much better about
doing it myself
so like i said he holds a special place
in my heart yay
that video really helped me when i was
very concerned about an all beef diet
he has a company called meat rx at
meadrx.com that offers a group for
people to go to who are trying the
carnivore diet or trying to get their
health under control
he has specialists on their recipes and
weekly meetings
for people with a ton of different
disorders and diseases
he's been given hell for charging for
this community and has criticized a ton
on
the media his social media can be a bit
blunt
but his heart is really in the right
place and i've seen the inside of meat
rx and it's great
shawn is the author of the book the
carnivore diet and a very good human
this episode is brought to you by my
favorite meat place true local
true local is my go-to place for meat in
canada code mp
will get you free steaks and i highly
recommend giving them a try if you want
some convenient and high quality meat in
toronto
they connect with local farmers and sell
their meat to you
you can edit your box online change
shipping frequency
just get one box if you want i believe i
have one set up to be delivered every
two weeks and every six weeks
that just has lamb i would recommend
their beef their grass-fed beef tastes
amazing unlike a lot of grass-fed beef
that you buy
they're lamb's the best lamb i've ever
had they're wild salmon's excellent too
and they're turkey they have chicken and
pork as well and a number of
spiced cuts available they ship
flash frozen straight to your door it's
super convenient available
all across canada so thank you very much
true local for
supporting me and being a great company
i
use codemp for free stakes on the large
box
and that'll let them know that you came
from here i hope you enjoy this episode
please leave a review or subscribe if
you like it and my newsletter
is at michaelapeterson.com and linked
below if you'd like to stay in touch in
a slightly more direct way
[Music]
dr sean baker welcome to my podcast well
mckayla it's a pleasure thanks for
having us good talking to you again
yeah last time we spoke i was on your
podcast
but that was a while ago i just i'll
i'll do this in the intro
but you are one of the people you're the
first carnivore that i
found online and hearing your story on
joe rogan was
something that made me feel way better
about doing an all meat diet so thank
you for that you have a special place in
my heart because of that
well well thanks for the acknowledgement
i appreciate it yeah it's been uh
you know a lot of people of course you
know obviously joe's podcast has
got a huge reach since a lot of people
are exposed to it that way and it's been
uh
very fortunate you know whether he knows
it or not he's kind of created a bit of
a monster but
yeah helped a lot of people though yes
it has helped a lot of people for sure
okay so i think what i'm going to do
well first could you give a bit of a
brief background about
who you are and what it is that you do
yeah so i mean
i'm my gosh what am i about turned 54 in
a couple weeks
uh you know i was i was an orthopedic
surgeon lifelong athlete
uh you know always kind of you know i
would say more of an athlete than a
surgeon
i kind of use surges my day job what i
really like doing was competing in
sports and i've been very fortunate to
have
you know broken world records in three
different sports over three different
decades recently most recent ones
in my 50s in rowing and then throwing in
my 40s and weightlifting powerlifting in
my 30s and
so i've always been interested in human
performance human physiology
obviously as a physician as a surgeon
you know you're obviously
well acquainted with uh the failings and
of the human body and then how to
hopefully fix it and make it work better
um you know i you know i went
traditional well not so much traditional
i had kind of a weird
circuitous route into you know medicine
i started out
college university of texas you know got
my you know my
bachelor's degree in science biology
went into medical school but then i
dropped out of medical school to play
rugby
went and played in new zealand for a
couple of seasons and then
kind of when i was done there i kind of
overstayed my welcome with visas and
stuff you know they don't want you there
too
long in new zealand so i came back and i
was so wanted to play so i joined the us
military and this is in the early 90s
and got trained as a nuclear weapons
launch officer so i was one of the guys
that would be
wow you know turning the key or pressing
the button to launch nuclear weapons had
we had gone to nuclear war we did you
know we did simulations and stuff so it
was a pretty
interesting job did that for about five
years and then i decided that i wanted
to go back to medical school and
i was tired playing rugby i was playing
rugby for the military team and
i remember i was in las vegas playing a
team of russians
and i was you know laying at the bottom
of the tile this guy was just repeatedly
kicking
me in the head and had blood coming out
of my ears
yeah those damn russians you know right
so you know but actually i didn't mind
because they were better than the dang
samoans the samoans were like block
people i mean they were like
like hitting brick walls the russians
released taller and they had
a little more give to them but um so i
decided well i'm not gonna
you know i'm not gonna play rugby
anymore let's go back to medical schools
the military sent me back
kicked in the head yeah right repeatedly
and that's probably wrong with me too
many kicks to the head perhaps but uh
so back to medical school you know
get out uh go into new mexico uh well
i went yeah i started new mexico and at
the kirkland air force base
gets sent immediately to afghanistan do
all kinds you know all this all kinds of
trauma you know pretty pretty severe
trauma spend
about six months over there come back
you know finish up my time in the
military going to private practice and
then i'm in my mid 40s you know
still doing the athletic stuff i was at
that time i think doing highland games i
just won world championships in highland
games
as a masters athlete and i
um decided like you know i'm not feeling
too good
i'm kind of you know this this eat
whatever you want type of thing
was catching up with me you know and i
was 300 pounds which is what i needed to
be for throwing stuff you know have you
seen the highlander how tall are you
i'm five people so six five three
hundred pounds i mean i was throwing you
know throwing the big telephone poles
the cabers and the
shot put type stuff and you know you
know they're just big people i mean
these guys are six
eight 350 pound monsters and to compete
with those guys you have to be big
but i probably was developing metabolic
syndrome and this is despite
working out hard i mean i was running
sprints lifting weights
doing all those things like i've been
done my whole all my life but despite
that
still started to see you know health
going down so i decided well i'm going
to change
i slim down to about 2 30 and about that
took me about
i don't know three or four months to do
that and i did it on a on a low fat
high vegetable lean protein diet uh
which worked
uh for sure but it was just i was just
miserable
i mean i was just like man i was like
i'm pissed off the nurses at the
hospital like we like the fat dr baker
way better you're kind of an [ __ ]
you know because i was i mean i was just
hungry all the time and i was grouchy
and
cranky and and just did that this wasn't
sustainable for me
uh and then i was exercising you know
just a ton to try to drop that away real
quick
uh and then just gosh you know six or
seven years of study and learning about
nutrition then
applying it on my patients uh you know
getting people to avoid
surgery which i thought was really
really cool having people come in with
you know with
you know needing a knee replacement
putting them on the diet and suddenly
their pain goes away and you
of all people understand what that is
man yeah i wish that it happened to me i
i honestly think i could have
probably reversed yeah you definitely
might have avoided you know hip and your
hip and ankle replacements like you have
but uh so and then then you know
got into this stuff and then kind of
slowly worked my way towards an all-meat
diet
uh and then kind of you know kind of
started on social media with this
it's kind of a joke at first most people
thought i was kidding around and then i
said look i really feel good
i mean this is this or something here
and there was a community that was
already
sort of evolving of a few thousand
people i was just kind of
kind of vicariously listening to them
watching them
and i was like i'm gonna try this and i
did and i just i was like wow this is
really the best i've felt
in i don't know when and and then as i
uh kind of sort of promoted a little bit
on social media
we got about 100 people to do it over
three months we actually recorded data
and we saw people on average losing
about 30 pounds in three months
they lost their weight their waste went
better everything got better for them
and then i think then that kind of at
some point right after that i think joe
rogan got picked that up and then you
know when you go on a show a lot of
people get exposed to you and then of
course you get attacked by all the
you know the angry folks the vegans the
people who think you're nuts and so i've
been you know kind of fighting the good
fight
for the last four years i'm about four
years into this now i think in about
what a couple weeks i'll be four years
doing this and
you know we're still still still going
strong so it's been fun
yeah um you put together
i know you had some sort of crowd
funding for research
so so what's happening with that because
people are definitely looking for some
solid studies they can refer
you know people complaining at them too
one of the main criticism is you know
there's people like you and me saying oh
we
we we feel better you know we generally
have improved health problems and i know
you've been subject to criticism
you supposedly had you know arthritis oh
i know
supposed arthritis you just went in
there and faked that with your face with
your total hip and total ankle just
because you supposedly had arthritis
it cracks me up when i hear that but so
we've got so many you know and i've
collected these all these anecdotes and
it's up to the
into the thousands now people that we've
had that have uh you know
really really fix some really nasty
things you know whether it's
uh significant musculoskeletal stuff
autoimmune things
you know mental health issues like ways
you know anxiety depression all those
things seem to get better when we change
your diet
um and then you know the criticism well
where's the long-term study where's
research this is all anecdotes it's your
useless information which
in truth it's not but uh so i you know
i finally got enough sort of i guess
following influence where we could try
to
see if we could you know get a study
done and
so david ludwig and harvard
contacted me and they've done they've
actually been writing up a study right
now it was just kind of a survey data
you know it's kind of taking people who
have already been doing this for six
months
and just characterizing them where were
you at when you started
where are you at now um what kind of
labs do you have
pre and post i've got 2 000 people that
participated i think 500
500 of them have you know a settle that
set of labs that they'll be able to look
at so that'll come out
but we're looking at doing an
interventional trial mm-hmm
that would be cool that'll be like we
take people who have never been on the
diet that are suffering
from some problem and see what happens
and we want to make sure we want to see
does it indeed work
how many of them does it seem to help um
how does it compare to a potential
control group
and then also importantly what is the
safety you know is is this dangerous you
know are they gonna
are they gonna get scurvy they're gonna
have heart attacks are they gonna have
all these untoward things that we're
told
are gonna happen which i've yet to see
happen you know despite
you know observing people for half a
decade and watching them
and not seeing all these negative things
happen but um so that that's the deal
there we are
um you know we're crowdfunding um you
know we've got
you know upwards about 140 000 raised so
far
um i'll probably start pushing that
again at the beginning of the year
you know probably will end up spending
about a half million dollars or so on
this and there may be some other sources
that
have potentially discussed coming and
help with this so i think we'll have a
really nice study done
i'm not the research i'm not doing it
i'm not the researcher we're going to
contract this out to professional
researchers to do this
yeah so it's you know it's above board
done while transparent you know it's all
you know done hopefully you know in a
good fashion that all
uh more people do this now you know many
people do it without it i mean
you know you don't need a research your
grandmother tells you what to eat your
mother tells you what to eat they're not
research scientists
so you know you can do whatever the heck
you want i think that's one of the
issues with we have people saying that
you know trying to tell you how to eat
and i'm like you eat over the house how
you want you know that's the time
yeah yeah so hopefully next year we'll
get we'll get rolling on this it could
it takes a while once it's funded
to to get it rolling and to enroll uh uh
participants you know to you know do the
whole thing probably
probably six months of duration that's
probably what we're looking at and then
you know what we're going to measure
been talking with a whole bunch of
different physicians that
treat patients with a carbohydrate and
seeing what kind of markers and outcomes
are probably the most effective to look
at that's going to be so interesting
any and it's a tricky study to do too
because
the people you're dealing with are
already sick
so the likelihood of something happening
to them is already
raised or are you going to deal with
people who are also like generally
healthy
well we're going to definitely have
people that have
issues you know we don't want somebody
that's on their deathbed you know
because that just you know that that and
most studies exclude that anyway if you
look at how our studies are designed
you don't want people that are true
they're going to drop out of the study
are going to have complications right
away but
you want to get you want to be able to
assess a condition and so it's probably
going to be
obesity diabetes hypertension
inflammatory issues
we see as you know a lot of autoimmune
things improve we see mental health
things
so if we get a big enough study we'll be
able to hopefully partition out a few of
those things and look at those
independently
perhaps or even write three four five
papers out of this and so that's uh
that's the plan with what we're doing oh
that would be so cool that would be so
helpful
and it can yeah that would be great i'm
really looking forward to that
so what is it there are a lot of
different now that carnivore the
carnivore guide is actually more popular
there are a lot of different
people saying different things what you
need what you don't need what the
carnivore diet is what works and what
doesn't
so what do you generally tell people and
what does your diet look like
yeah that's a great question as this has
evolved there evolver a lot of people
different have different sort of uh
thoughts and opinions on uh you know
what what's necessary what's not
you know i've i looked at about twelve
thousand people doing this and i
basically specifically asked them
you know what are you eating what's
working for you what are your outcomes
been and what we're seeing is that
uh generally uh you know
well let's just talk about the
difference there's people that say you
must eat
you know a grass-finished product to
have
not not just good outcomes but optimal
outcomes and anything that it isn't that
is a problem there's other people say
you must eat x amount of
these particular organ meats you're
going to have problems and when you look
at the actual data
on the people that have done this you
know i
i don't see a huge difference between
those that do and those that don't now
there are individuals that certainly
um do have
you know improvements when they include
say organ meats or
they may prefer grass finish but they're
conversely there's people that do better
on grain finished beef so this is kind
of an interesting thing and i know it
goes against
the sort of the feel good narrative of
you know we want these ethically raised
animals and green pastures and all that
stuff but
the data is what it is and you know i'm
i'm hoping and there are some
researchers that are starting to look at
this
uh because when i've surveyed you know
like i said ten
ten plus thousand people eighty-five
percent of them do not eat organ meats
on a regular basis only 15 percent do
and the outcomes were no different when
you looked at
coming off meds you know all these
improvements in their health
i couldn't find a difference there so
it's kind of like if you want to do it
that's great if
it does help you that's certainly great
if you have environmental
or ethical reasons that lead you to that
that's also great
but when you have people that are saying
you must do it this way or you're going
to be sick or you're
not optimal or you're sort of on the jv
team
i kind of push back on that because
that's not what the the actual
experience has been and i
i try to be very um
very much reserved in what i'm willing
to say
based on actual human outcomes and i
think there's a lot of speculation
based on some of the science that we
have some of the biochemistry
and some of the metabolic pathways and
it's just
it's all conjecture and i'm like i i
want to know when when the rubber
hits the road are people getting better
or not that's all i really care about
and if it matches your your your ethics
that's great if it doesn't sorry
you know this is what veganism does you
know this is not a reverse veganism
situation this isn't i have an ideology
and i believe we should
raise animals this way and therefore i'm
going to sort of
mission the environment and health with
that you know we have to keep everything
separate in my view
yeah i did a podcast with rob wolf and
he came out with
a book i think it was called sacred cow
and he actually
got scientists that weren't involved in
the book to look at the differences
between grass fed and
grain finished i guess beef corn fed
and decided even though he was
pro-grass-fed
beef decided that the nutrient
differences wasn't really worth
mentioning that was his outcome with the
book which was
which was interesting i found i've
talked again in fred provenza and
there's another research name stefan van
bleeck
out of duke university doing actually
doing this research
you know they can definitely see there's
differences in some of the some of the
uh
differences in in the way the animals
are raised and what they're fed at the
end
but again does it affect humans that's
the unknown part
and they are starting to do that
research so i mean my hope truly is that
that it shows that if a regenerative
range of animals is
significantly better for humans that
would be a great cell for that
but again until we have that data i'm
not willing to
to tell people don't eat meat from from
the grocery store because it's poison
like i hear some people doing that and
it's really yeah
unfortunately limiting to people yeah
and my my main issue with it like
i think i i haven't really found a
difference
i was fairly sick right and i haven't
really found a difference between
even corn fed mostly what we get in
canada is grain finished or grass-fed
corn fed is a little bit more rare and
sometimes i find maybe it's harder on my
digestion
possibly but i'm not sure but my main
concern for people saying
you have to eat grass-fed is there are
so many barriers
especially for people who are really
sick there are already so many barriers
to trying this diet
that's saying you need only
grass-finished beef
that's going to cut out a whole bunch of
people because they're like i can't
afford that i don't even know where to
get that or what that is
or saying i need grassiness beef plus
organs
and then that'll cut out a whole bunch
of people who would have been willing to
try the diet
uh if you had just said hey just eat
meat right it's much easier sell
um so that's what i'm concerned when
there are all these like
there's all these rules involved that
don't necessarily have evidence for them
i think
yeah i think when you unnecessarily
complicate things it does it does turn a
lot of people off and you know
one of the one of the i think the nice
things about i know you've
sort of coined the lion diet which you
know be salt and water and i mean it's
very much it's very simple
and and you know it takes a lot of the
guesswork and the calculations and the
fatigue you get with trying to you know
and the anxiety because it's like
there's so much even on like a ketogenic
diet i mean you're like you're
constantly worried about macronutrient
ratios and measuring ketones and
trying to put together recipes and it's
just it can be exhausting where
when you tell people hey just just go
eat some steaks and or
hamburger and whatever and to see
something you enjoy and
you know when you're full stop eating
and eat again when you're hungry and
then that message
works for a large number of people maybe
not every single person
and it's certainly not necessary for
everybody to do that and i've never said
that
but that's a much different message than
saying you have to eat
you know 1.6 you know grams of
this a day and you know 25 grams of
kidney and
75 grams of liver and you know get your
brain and get your macronutrient ratio
here
that that i think that's just a
kind of a that's going to lose its
appeal pretty quickly and it's going to
turn a lot of people off this and you
know you see as you know i mean
this is obviously this gets a little bit
more
you know i guess controversial but we
see a lot of this
media manipulation of of what
you know what we're supposed to do and
even when they talk about the carnivore
diet it's mostly been negative obviously
it's been in a negative light
and they always almost always will like
to show somebody eating raw brains or
something like that yeah
yeah it's like they put the people in oh
yeah but this person he's eating raw
kidneys how disgusting is that
or to the average person there's people
that are fine with that there's other
cultures that wouldn't bat an eye but
in western culture you know they try to
portray everybody on a carnivore diet is
near cannibalistic you know here we are
eating raw meat all day long and raw you
know raw organs
and i think that's just a way to try to
scare people i mean we see all this
stuff this just trying to paint
fear in in not well you know we we can
go into
a lot of things with this topic with
fear in the media but uh yeah
um you know i i see that with this diet
now i would
for you know we're not at the point
where we're seeing frank
censorship yet i mean we are to some
degree you know there's there's you know
there's like if you question
a lot of topics and i'm not necessarily
i'm pro or con
on any of these things but i mean you
know we saw this with coronavirus with
the covid with
vaccine no vaccine mask no mask lockdown
no lockdown you know
cholesterol deniers you know and soon
it's going to be is it going to be
you know you're oh my god you're not
eating vegetables how dare you promote
that
yeah and then we're going to be censored
and so i'm i am a little concerned about
that i don't know what your thoughts are
on
on where we're going with that stuff uh
i don't know like i like to stay pretty
positive but i did get demonetized after
i put up a video about how i
i literally had coronavirus and i put up
my coronavirus experience and i got
demonetized i haven't been remonetized
um i don't know if that was a
coincidence because i didn't i didn't
have strikes didn't tell me anything
and fortunately for me it's not it
doesn't really
like make a difference to me but that
could really
stop some people um and it's just
interesting when it happened i just
joined
parlor i know that's had like a
skyrocket of downloads recently so
i'm trying to kind of just put things
put myself
out in on many different platforms just
in case
but i don't know i don't know what's
gonna happen
are you on parlor yet yeah i actually
joined july 4th
2020. uh then i kind of did it for a
while and i was inactive and then i you
know i just
you know i mean it's interesting
to see how much control
these tech companies have over what
things play out what things are allowed
to be seen what thoughts are allowed to
be expressed
and you know if you're if you agree with
what the message is no problem but if
you start stepping out the lines and
certainly
my dietary philosophy might challenge i
think it's on the edge and then a lot of
people that
do that also have views that are maybe
not popular whether it's political or
other other healthcare things
and so you're kind of walking that line
so yeah i i've been on parlor
for a while and uh parlay and uh
oh is it parlay i think it's for french
french
that makes more sense than parlor yeah
parlay for for speaking you know
parliament
yeah yeah that doesn't make sense so
anyway i don't know why they maybe it's
a french company i don't know where's or
maybe it's maybe it's french canadian
maybe it's up there in your quebecois
type
type of land so it's not possible it
could be they could be organized enough
to come up with an app
i'm allowed to say that i was born in
montreal all right okay
yeah yeah so we're we're seeing uh you
know like i said it
but it's how they how you the message
can be controlled whether it's a
political message whether it's a health
message
you know and there's a lot of silicon
valley money that's going into
this progression of you know fake meat
lab-grown meat you know this is sort of
you know trying to do this
uh you know i i did i just did a very
interesting podcast with kate brown
who's a who's a big guy in the
regenerative
ag world and he's saying you know he's
he's doing a lot of business
with regenerative agriculture and i'm a
big i'm a big proponent of that don't
get me wrong i think that's the right
way to go
whether it's in the u.s canada or
elsewhere in the world and he said
they're talking with some of the like
there's four major beef producers in the
u.s
there's jbs tyson cargill and national
beef which is bought by marfrick another
south american company or brazilian
company
and i know he's having discussions with
one of those companies about starting a
regenerative line so i think as the
market forces drive that
um that will help fill that out they
said they've got about 22 million acres
and they've converted
you know versus zero three and a half
years ago for their company
projecting 100 million acres converted
to regenerative ag by
by the next five years and so we get
these big companies behind that
um we might see some good things come
out of that you know they're gonna you
know like i said they're gonna go where
the money is and where the market demand
is and so if consumers want to eat human
pet food which was
which is what i call that beyond meat
impossible burger garbage
then fine uh but if we want to eat
regeneratively grown meat and fix the
soil and
fix the biodiversity then that should
also be will also be promoted if
we you know decide to do that so i think
that is important i think that will
i mean i could just be in a circle of
people who know about regenerative
agriculture it's hard to tell with
social media but i do think that that
seems to be taking off
you do see some articles occasionally
that are like hey maybe this is actually
good for the environment
occasionally so i think that will go
somewhere
i do and i think the the fact that and i
don't know that's going to be through
government mandate but i do think it's
through
market demand and the fact that industry
is taking an interest so they're showing
it
you know you know people that rely on
the government i think are
are often sadly disappointed with the
results and i think you know we do have
uh when the corporations decide it's in
their best interest
you know then they get things done
that's just the reality of it whether
it's
you know building cars or computers for
sure or whatever it might be
uh government tends to often slow things
down at least that's been my my
perspective
i just had bjorn lomberg on the podcast
and he does he talks about climate and
he thought that the way to solve climate
was through innovation
and it was going to be through companies
coming up with things that actually
consumers would buy and it would just
work that way
he's is he swedish a camera i know he's
somewhere i'm scandinavian somewhere
maybe
oh my god i can't remember yeah i've
seen his writing before yeah that's okay
from copenhagen copenhagen yeah he's
really smart that was that was a fun one
okay i want to switch directions
slightly and shoot over some questions
um
that some people on instagram asked that
are commonly asked
um one of them when from what you've
seen
how long do people have to do this type
of like restrictive carnivore diet
in order to see some sort of benefit and
are there downsides like what's the
first period of time like
yeah so and this is i go back to the
survey data we did with 12 000 people
uh we saw a really significant shift in
outcomes that by about the three month
point
so you know for many people we saw like
if we just say overall health you know
some of it was did you get off
medications did this or that improve so
and so we talked about exercise and
endurance and strength and
conditioning type stuff but you know for
the first 60 you know
30 60 90 days a certain percentage
people got better or some got very good
but then in three months it just shot up
pretty significantly to where
a significant percentage of the people
got better and then by six months a
little more than by
i think a little longer than that and
then how strict people were we saw that
70 strict got to a certain result and
then 80 was that 10 better than 90
percent of the whole 10 better
than going from 90 to 100 percent maybe
a five percent difference so there is a
little bit of wiggle room it seems
for many people um you know so i would
say that three-month
point you know we often have these
30-day challenges just to get people
doing it because
yeah most people can commit to 30 days
and you start telling them three months
is hard that's too much but it does seem
that three months is is a is an
inflection point for a lot of people
and then the other thing is you know
transition yeah i mean it's you know
it's your sweet you know if you're
coming from a
car based diet you're going to be
switching energy systems
to some degree it's not like you go it's
not all or nothing it's just a shift you
know
you start relying a little bit more on
fat and a little less on glucose
you know the the energy tends to
stabilize instead of having the
you know the constant ups and downs with
the food um you know your bowel habits
are going to change as you know you're
not you're just not wasting stuff and so
these people mistake constipation oh my
god i haven't had a bowel movement in
two days
they start freaking out about that and
you're like well you just you're just
absorbing everything you're not wasting
you know you're not wasting all that
food that you eat you know when you have
a high fiber diet you know you eat it
and it just goes right through you
and a lot of that nutrition ends up in
the toilet so it's kind of like almost
waste of money at night
it's hard for people to believe though
like going from a high fiber diet over
it's
such a dramatic change people are like
yeah
three times a day to once every three
days yeah it can be you know and
it and it varies from person to person
um you know there's some electrolyte
shifts that happen you know when you're
you see a drop in your insulin levels
typically and
many people would argue that's a good
thing but we do know that insulin will
cause the kidneys to retain salt and
water and so you'll go from
you know maybe having a little bit more
fluid on you to having some less
you may be looking less puffy as some
people say a lot of people see facial
inflammation go down
yeah um but when that occurs you know
you have this loss of electrolytes and
so some people will get
a headache some people you know they
call it like a keto flu
they might notice their heart beating
stronger they might notice you know that
you know
uh differences in how they sleep and so
sometimes you have to supplement that
with electrolytes to start out in the
beginning
and that doesn't always necessarily stay
long-term because i i
do see people that they start out eating
a lot of salt and then they continue
that habit and then they start saying
well i'm
getting swollen feet i'm like you're
over salting you've got to cut back a
little bit so
those are the major things i mean
there's a few other things that
pop up occasionally but generally
uh the first few weeks are probably for
most people rough as you know some
people develop
uh you know diarrhea you know some
people could constipate some people were
well
as i know and told the entire world
also made to mention that you know oh
true yeah it's kind of interesting but
yeah it's
it's uh and like i said it may not work
for everybody well it doesn't work for
every single person but it does seem to
work for a lot of people
and i tend to do this as a tool
you use it as a tool to fix things and
you find it as a baseline i almost kind
of consider it like a reset button
because when you were born you were
eating an animal-based diet now granted
it was breast milk but
still you weren't eating fiber you
weren't eating plant foods you weren't
eating phytonutrients
uh and so you go back to that to like
when you're just born and some of these
things are
you know you kind of go back to that new
point and then you might be able to find
that you can tolerate things i don't
know where you are if you've
found that you could incorporate because
the last time i talked to you really
you try really smart yeah and then and
then where
are you at today are you a little more
i'm i'm actually much
okay so i'm still strict right like i'm
i'm actually mostly
eating lamb which i haven't really told
people because an all lamb diet would
get so much more flack than an all beef
diet
but i'm mainly eating lamb i found the
longer on the diet
my body got a little bit more sensitive
to the amount of fat i was eating
so my digestion is like still it's good
it's good if i mean like eating lamb
it's fine
but my digestion's been a bit off i can
drink tea now without having autoimmune
symptoms
i couldn't drink tea i couldn't have any
spices without having these huge
flare-ups i tried to reintroduce my
husband actually was like
maybe it's better to have a few plants
and i was like well it's been
almost three years maybe i'll try and it
had been long enough without a severe
autoimmune
like issue that i was brave enough to
try it so i tried reintroducing like
pressure cooked apples with no skin
which was pretty safe and
i over the next so i didn't have a huge
flare up but over the next three weeks
i ended up getting more bloated for sure
and then my skin started breaking out
and then my joints started hurting and
then i started getting a little moody
so it wasn't like it used to be which
was just a catastrophe
um i i also couldn't stop freaking
eating this stupid fruit
like if it was in the fridge i'd be like
well
don't mind me i'll have a whole bunch of
berries and
that was actually probably the most
annoying part i missed just being like
eat till i'm full and then i'm done
instead of this always nagging like have
more berries
and so i generally tell people the same
thing like get your baseline of health
wait until you're feeling good and then
try reintroducing
maybe don't splurge on like soy like
just be careful try reintroducing and
see what happens but
i'm still doing i'm like almost all
beef lamb i can now eat fish i didn't
used to be
able to eat salmon and one thing
actually that i should tell you
uh so i haven't really found much
difference between ruminant meat and
what they're
fed and my response but i cannot eat
farmed salmon
i'll i'll get a rash i'll my i won't
feel good mentally like it's it's
it's intense and i was not that
surprised i guess because
but it was quite intense so it was a bit
surprising
i think it's pretty well accepted that
you know the the ruminant animals have
such more
processing capability and detoxification
capability what they're fed
relative to another animal i you know we
typically talk about monogastrics
one stomach like humans and pigs and
dogs and not that we're eating dogs
typically at least not here
and uh chickens i don't know about fish
i think
i'm pretty sure fish are monogastric
animals yeah they are
so that may that may be something to do
with that but
uh i you know like for me i mean i eat
you know i i went
for many years eating just pretty much
straight up red meat
nothing else and and i occasionally have
a little bit more right now i'm in the
process of trying to
gain some weight so i'm eating a lot of
uh eggs and some dairy and
a lot of just a lot of calories and it's
just kind of funny i mean because people
told me
well you can't get a lean on a carnivore
night so i got super lean
and and now then they're saying well you
can't put muscle on on a car or that so
now i'm doing the opposite so
it's just uh just kind of you know just
kind of kind of play and do the
different experiments
but uh just to show that you can do it
so you know you can do whatever you want
you know it's just a matter of
you know eating enough or eating the
right amounts and that works
just like any other diet yeah how do you
find
clinically how do you find people's
response to dairy
i'd say overall the general
is is probably a negative i mean this is
i mean if i were to look at all people
across the board there are certainly
some people who do just fine with dairy
most people tend to limit it you know
there are people that will claim that if
i can get it raw dairy
raw cheese yeah is there anything behind
that do you think
well i mean there's speculation behind
that i mean i've you know i
i've talked to people from both sides of
it uh you know there's people that are
certainly concerned with raw
dairy being a problem with regard to
infection risk
now what is true that you know if you
look like the u.s stats on
on raw dairy versus you know pasteurized
dairy
both of them can cause infections in
humans we've had outbreaks in in that
there tends to be more per capita with
raw dairy
than with pasteurizer but they both can
do it but the overall rate is so small
regardless i mean it's like you know
your
your odds are like kind of like getting
struck by lightning it's not very likely
uh particularly if you're kind of
careful about your sourcing about that
now
in the u.s um it's mostly legal in most
of the states
uh some of it you have to you have to
get pet dairy because
you know just this is somatics and you
drink the pet dairy you know it's
labeled as pet dairy not nuts fit for
human consumption but people do it
anyway but
you know it's one of those controversial
topics that we don't have good data on
and there's
there's uh people that are proponents
very strong components of
from both sides and i you know i've
tried raw dairy
i didn't notice any huge improvement i
didn't notice any
negatives either so it's one of those
things that i think is highly individual
i think
you know the dairy you know there's
places like scandinavia where they just
this is where they have the most dairy
in the world and they have
in many cases some of the longest life
expectancy in the world now the people
will counter that they have
higher rates of type 1 diabetes and
maybe it's because of dairy for that so
we don't know
i think it's i think it's i think it is
individual with regard to dairy
yeah my experience with like when i
first started cutting out foods i cut
out
grains and soy and dairy those were the
top inflammatory ones for arthritis
specifically
and my mood um but it's hard to say i
i've spoken with a number of people like
the person who came up with the gaps
diet
which is actually very similar she
starts off on a carnivore diet for
people and then reintroduces foods
and she was intense about the necessity
of
raw dairy from a very certain type of i
guess a2 cow and she's like that is how
you get your microbiome back and that's
how you manage to eat vegetables again
um this like older russian lady who is
pretty cool
uh but i'm too like concerned about my
reaction to dairy to even bother with
that
plus i like the diet there's a lot of
people that do fine with that dairy i
mean that's clear
i've seen that over and over again and
you know the microbiome stuff i think is
still we're still so
far premature to start to say
this is the the perfect microbiome we
just don't know and i think anybody
that's saying that
is well well ahead of where the science
really is
and i think that's a little bit sort of
maybe disingenuous to say stuff like
that but i mean you know there was a you
know there's research it just came out
showing that
meat-based diets promote a microorganism
called bilothala
and and that has been associated with
healthy people with good outcomes and
good cardiovascular outcomes
and that's from eating meat and so you
know it goes back and forth
you know you can find like i said this
is what i always say you know if you're
looking for
uh you know uh validation of what you
want to believe you can find it in
in the uh in the literature there's so
many studies out there you whatever you
want to believe you can find validation
on that
but if you really want results you got
to look in the mirror and you then you
know i think that's the most powerful
thing you look
am i better today than i was yesterday
and i think that's
clear to most people you know your
beliefs can be you know you can find any
newspaper article or scientific study
but
its results are either there and you
know you know you know you're in pain or
you're not in pain you know and it's
it's
it's pretty clear to me yeah and it's
really complicated to try and figure out
i tried figuring out my health by
looking at scientific articles that's
where i started
and that eventually led me to the
conclusion that gluten was probably
contributing to my health problems
so at least i got there through the
scientific articles but
after eliminating gluten there wasn't
anything that i could trust
other than me testing things out on my
own body and then
writing down my symptoms every day so
yeah i mean you mean you literally can
go do a google search on any food
any food and say is it bad for me and
you'll find
articles say yes articles say no many of
them like the scientific study so it's
it's really a
you know almost a fool's errand to try
to do that that way i think you just
have to
like i said i think these elimination
diets are a very good idea for many
people whether you do carnivore or some
other elimination diet
see where you're at be objective write
it down and then
you know add back in subtract whatever
you need to do when you get to carnivore
diet there's not much to
to subtract you're kind of you're down
to the
yeah in my view the the most safe food
out there and it's interesting i
lectured in malaysia
uh a little about this time last year
and one of the lecturers was from
uh cambridge university in in england
and he said he'd been doing food
sensitivity and immune
assay tests on people looking at you
know what foods they were consuming and
he'd been doing something like a quarter
of a million every year
for 20 years so that's over 5 million
tests he said the only food that almost
never is reactive was basically red room
than meat
and so everything else whether it's
shell foods you know dairy
eggs and all kinds of plant foods they
all have a certain background amount of
reactivity and
sensitivity problems red meat was almost
never
associated with that which is kind of
what we're seeing i think
so this was scary so when i reintroduced
plant foods this summer after not eating
them for a really long time i did food
sensitivity testing a number of
different ways blood work because it was
like i haven't eaten plants in three
years i wonder what's going to happen
my uh immunoglobulin g levels
spiked to almost everything i was eating
including beef
which has never happened before so my
entire my body got angry at everything i
was eating
and that's when i kind of switched to
lamb and was like that's a
i wasn't reacting to beef but it was not
sitting well and
so that was really scary and it seems to
be fine now
but like when i did reintroduce the
plants and then after about three weeks
of like
kind of feeling not so good my body did
not seem happy with anything
so i wanted to put that out because i
was like you know be careful if you
have a really severe autoimmune disorder
and you have it in remission maybe like
don't screw around too much
maybe i'm back i'm back to like beef is
fine now but it did spike up and it had
never done that before
interesting yeah that was scary lamb is
a great option i mean it's a great great
food i mean we don't eat it much
and i don't know but canada in the us
it's a very underappreciated meet but
you go to
new zealand iceland you know france uk i
mean they
they'll eat it quite a bit and so i
think it's a very good very good option
for many people
yeah i love it and i've spoken with like
i've got a couple of facebook groups
where
really sick people go to complain at
each other
but um a lot of people there sometimes
a lot of people actually have difficulty
digesting some of the fat
in beef especially nearer to the
beginning of the diet and actually have
an easier time with lamb
and i'm not entirely sure why that is
even veal so i'm wondering if that has
something to do
with the type of beef they're eating
that's the only time i've ever come
close to being
like maybe it's because some people are
sensitive to the fact that some beef or
some cows are eating corn i don't know
because
i do find people sometimes have an
easier time with veal
um but i have no idea lamb is good
anyway i've been eating a ton of it
recently
although i might like i said i'm back to
being fine with any type of beef but it
was scary there for a minute
one of the exciting things that you know
we've got this
project or company called meatrx.com and
you know i'm a ceo my partner is a
tech founder you know uh entrepreneur
out of silicon valley
and with a machine learning ai
background and so we're going to be
looking at
a lot of these things you know and
trying to plug that into ai to see if we
can start to figure out and make sense
of
these little nuances and we're trying to
figure out algorithms that you know
why are these things happening which
people just seem to be happening to more
can we tailor things a little bit and so
that's uh you know it's it's it's in
development as we get more and more data
and we sort
of data for that we can start to sort of
figure that out and so if we get
you know more feedback the quicker we'll
be able to start to
to figure out some of this stuff because
yeah i look at the the way we
we practice healthcare these days as a
physician from this system
you know it's kind of this top-down
model you know we have a problem that's
identified within the community we kind
of say okay drug companies you guys
solve this
that's allopathic medicine in a nutshell
basically and then they you know they
their
their goal is to make them the
billion-dollar drug so their
shareholders
and board of directors is happy and they
you know they they find something that
helps a little bit or maybe improves
upon the previous generation of medicine
and you know they run the studies and
you know then they tell the various
patient advocacy bodies these american
heart association american diabetes
association whatever
to start advocating for it they get
their physician advocates that start
giving lectures and lectures to other
physicians
and then it comes down to the you know
the the sort of the frontline physicians
who then push it down onto the patients
and this is top down model with the goal
at the end really being can we
make a billion dollar drug and get
enough people to use it whereas what
we're doing is taking a bunch of people
that are that have illnesses and they're
figuring out
what's working for them and this is
again an absence of drugs by using
lifestyle measures whether it's exercise
diet sleep
you know you know sunlight exposure
sauna whatever you want to put out there
and then certainly food
and then we collect enough data there
and we can say okay wait a minute now we
can feed this up
and maybe we can convince a few
physicians we already have we have
hundreds if not thousands of physicians
now they're saying hey maybe this red
meat stuff isn't all that bad
and yes maybe i can use it for certain
patients that have autoimmune disease
you know
crohn's disease you know ulcerative
colitis yeah perhaps it's safer than
immune suppressants
yeah chris chris palmer out at harvard
university doing
psychiatric research on caramel or
ketogenic diets showing that
yeah there's people that have
schizophrenia that go away when you put
them on the right diet
so this is i think this is a way forward
now again it's certainly
not going to make a billion dollar
profit for a company but i think
in the end ultimately it's going to help
uh more people
at the end of the day and so i think
what we're doing despite being
constantly
as you know you and i and others have
been constantly on
you know just attacked basically for
lack of a better word because they're
just
upset they're upset that how dare you
pretend you're healthy and and eat
vegetables and fruits and grains and the
stuff we want you to
we want you to eat how dare you do that
i even get where i like it doesn't even
make me that mad because
i kind of get where people are coming
from like when i was
incredibly ill and didn't trust i didn't
trust alternative medicine
in the least and part of that was
because i'd been to a number of
naturopaths and alternative
practitioners and i hadn't
my my mom had spent hundreds of dollars
on supplements
so i'd been like my mom just got screwed
over because she was trying to take care
of a sick kid
and that was my experience with
alternative medicine so i get the
you know the it's not right because the
carnivore there's actually something to
the carnivore diet but i understand why
people are angry because they don't want
sick people taken advantage of
but they don't understand that sick
people are actually taken advantage of
by the
normal medical system like for sure
yeah and i and i'm skeptical with most
alternative medicine to be honest i've
been a very conservative person as far
as what i'm
what i believe i mean i still i mean
when you think about it i mean my
basic views are hard work consistency
a good healthy diet and you know i look
at this diet it's like you don't eat a
lot of processed food you don't need a
lot of junk food you're not eating a lot
of
refined sugars you're eating a very
nutrient-rich
diet that's higher in protein than most
people get
i think those are all very good things
it tends not to be irritating the gi
tract it's simple to follow uh you know
it's it's it's generally pretty
palatable for most people particularly
if you know how to cook
i mean that's a skill i mean i think if
you don't know how to cook here you
really
well you can that's a problem you can
live today very easily and not know how
to cook you can spend your whole life
not knowing how to cook go to
restaurants
order in from eats or eat microwave food
or packaged food
and you could live your whole life that
way so cooking cooking is becoming this
sort of forgotten skill and i think it's
essential to health in my view quite
honestly so
we have to know how to cook and continue
to do and you've got a little girl
hopefully she'll learn how to cook i'm
teaching my kids how to cook
because it's so important um but you
know we've got this you know this
alternative medicine yeah they do rip
off a lot of people i see like some of
these functional medicine practitioners
before you even get in the doorway you
spent
a thousand dollars on labs and they've
not even said hi to you yet and i'm like
where where does this model come in this
doesn't make sense
uh so i i do i am a little skeptical of
that and so i think with the carnivore
diet is
hey eat a bunch of meat it's not like
you're you're you're
taking advantage with people and selling
them hundreds of supplements you're
saying hey
try this diet cut out a bunch of stuff
you know see what happens if you just
eat meat
it works it works if it doesn't it does
it and that's the end of it i mean it's
pretty
pretty simple for the most part i'm
working on a recipe book
which i think is going to be good
because i hate cooking and i was
actually a pretty good cook for a
variety of things but i don't like it i
didn't like grocery shopping
i didn't like cleaning up like i didn't
really like any of that stuff
but i have completely mastered the air
fryer and pressure cooker
and so i'm working on that so it'll be
out eventually
try and get people because a lot of
people are turned off in the first month
too because they're eating
like gray ground beef and it's repulsive
yeah i think i think that's a that's a
problem we see like a lot of uh you know
you get these vegetarians vegans
uh that their parents they weren't very
cooks and they were
all they were used to his eating was
chewy tough overcooked meats
lean meat yeah yeah and it's like well
no wonder you don't like it
but once you start learning how to how
to barbecue stuff
barbecue smoke slow cook you know i just
just cook a decent steak
goodness it's a game changer really is
so hopefully more people will
i'm not hopeful but you know some people
will hopefully
i'm hopeful you're always hopeful yeah
okay uh two questions i definitely want
to cover
these were the more controversial ones
within the carnivore community
one you had a blood test and first i
want to give you my guess
i'm not a doctor and i just want to know
if i'm on the right track but you had a
blood test a number of years ago and
your glucose was high
and my thoughts because i've done
fasting
and when i fasted and exercised one time
my glucose
shot up so i was wondering if you think
the reason the glucose was high
was because of how much you exercise if
that had anything to do with it or you
have an explanation there
certainly we know that and there's
actually some studies out that do this
certainly we know that
certain types of exercise anaerobic
exercise in particular
particularly hard sprinting will
dramatically increase the output of
glucose that your liver will put out you
know we see that the liver can put up
1500 percent more glucose when we're
exercising versus not exercising
wow and not only was i exercising out i
was exercising
almost every day uh
you know at a pretty much world-class
level i mean i was like
world record holding pace in a very
highly glycolytic situation so my
deliver was probably being taxed
to the max and responding and getting
better at it so i could produce
huge amounts of glucose in a short
period of time and i was doing that
uh very frequently throughout the day uh
there's somewhat of an anticipated
response response i usually train in the
morning
um and so you know just
thinking about exercise will raise your
blood glucose
uh so there's you know there there's
definitely
that we know like there's a study
there's a 2016 study looking at
i think it was called the titles i think
it was looking at continuous glucose
monitors
and i guess sub elite athletes these
were cyclists that were training very
very hard
and we certainly saw the ones that were
training the hardest
and the ones who were eating the lowest
carbohydrate content had the highest
fasting blood glucoses and so this kind
of goes
with that now subsequently like you know
you know i've actually been checking my
blood glucose pretty recently so just
before
this podcast it was 86 you know got
about an hour ago
or where's 85 i think the obligation was
85 and the us which is
well normal is typically somewhere in
somewhere below 100 down to 60 typically
in that range
and it depends on how much protein i'm
eating quite honestly
um if i'm eating a little bit more fat
the protein will go down if i mean a
little bit more protein fat i'll go up a
little bit
but i've now when i exercise i
sort of tailor the way i do it and i
wasn't taking a big long cooldown period
and that's the other thing is you know
you you can so the converse is if you do
just kind of this slow
steady state modern intense exercise
like even going for a brisk walk
will drop your blood glucose quite a bit
that's why a lot of people recommend
i'll walk after meals because it'll drop
your glucose and i wasn't doing that
because i was pretty pressed for time so
i would train i'd go in there and just
crush it crush it crush it you know
world-class level
my blood glucose probably stayed up
popped up and then came down a little
bit slower
and honestly i had a background history
that i was probably pre-diabetic
you know going into this from years
before so i probably have a little bit
of that pathophysiology going on and so
when you
so when you dump in this super high
intense exercise without
you know the proper sort of way to
dispose of that
you're going to see a little elevation
we know like again
back in the 1920s when they did
metabolism studies on
the inuit they saw that fasting blood
glucoses typically in the 120s
were common among and they didn't have
diabetes they didn't have
wow health issues they were and they
were routinely eating anywhere between
four to eight pounds of meat a day
part of the reason is because it's so
damn cold that you know you need more
food
because you're burning a lot more
calories to maintain body heat so they
were eating quite a bit
but we saw that but they didn't have you
know they weren't developing kidney
issues or eye issues or cardiovascular
issues
like you would see in someone that has
long-standing diabetes despite the fact
that their blood glucose was high i
wrote an article on that
several years ago when people ask me
about that but that's you know that was
what was going on now
like i said i still train hard uh but i
just kind of
been a little bit more judicious about
when i do the heart spreading and how i
recover from that
okay that was that was the first one and
the second one is i
i was doing other things and was not
involved in this debate but there was a
huge honey debate about whether or not
honey is good or part of the carnivore
diet or
not part of it so what's your opinion on
the potential benefits
or not benefits of honey well i mean i
i i tend to tell people i'm not your
mother and i'm not it's not some law and
this isn't a cult and this isn't a
you know this is strict or this is that
i just don't get into that stuff i mean
like any i mean i get people constantly
ask me can i have this can i have that
can i have milk can i have honey can i
have
a little bit of fruit i said i don't
know i mean it's up to you to test it
out and see so
just to put that part out there i don't
really
get i don't really draw lines on what
specifically is perfect
i would say test it out for yourself now
having said that i mean
honey is is a form of sugar there's no
doubt about it it's glucose sucrose
fructose in there
um you know there are some you know
nutrients in honey that are outside of
say pure table sugar so there's some
additional nutrition in there you might
benefit from that and there's people
that'll say that you know this is
more helpful for whatever reason i mean
it's clear that
people that eat a lot of sugar whether
it's coming from honey or soda pop or
you know whatever have dental issues i
mean we see that with the hodgson tribe
you know the males that
are out there you know chewing on the
honeycomb they have a much higher rate
of dental caries you know cavities than
the females do
um you know it's not it's it's not
even surprising really well i know it's
not me to pretend
they tend to gorge on it when they get
it at times and so they they pay with
dental problems
um you know is it better than table
sugar for somebody
marginally but it's not some super food
you can eat unlimited quantities it's
like anything else if you eat a lot of
it
it's going to be a problem you know we
do know that lots of fructose
it can lead to fat in the liver through
you know
uh denova lipogenesis you know fructose
there's clear pathways that do that
fructose has effects on you know
microbiome stuff
again again a microbiota i hate to use
microbiome stuff because i don't think
we know enough about
it but um having said that some people
can have honey and they do just fine
and they don't have issues with it good
for them i mean i don't really
i don't really care one way or another
but again this is so we have this belief
that
if you go on a low carb or ketogenic or
carnivore diet you do it long term
um you're going to have elevated
cortisol levels
and you've got you've got to have some
sugar you just got to eat sugar this is
oh i haven't heard that well there's
this there's this guy
named ray pete who's he's in his 80s or
something now and he
quoting a lot of studies from the 1970s
looking at that and looking at cortisol
levels and seeing that
gluconeogenesis can be impacted by
cortisol and if you're not
ingesting carbohydrates and
gluconeogenesis is going to be providing
your your your circulating glucose which
there's some truth to that but
the fact of the matter is you know
gluconeogenesis and
glycogen glycogenolysis which is a
breakdown of glycogen in the liver to
produce glucose
can occur with minimal elevations and
cortisol in fact glucagon can do almost
all of it we there are studies out there
showing that
as your blood glucose gets down to a
lower level glucagon kicks in
and that's sufficient enough to raise
your glucose back up and if it gets down
really really low
then you see a quarter or the cortisol
response but you'll get that with stress
fighters flight reflex which extreme
exercise you might see with cortisol
elevate and that'll drive that glucose
up and so that's going on
but to say that you can't have
gluconeogenesis or
glucose supply without significantly
raising your cortisol it's false in fact
jeff folek did a study in i think 2004
looking at people on a long-term
low-carb diet and saw no elevation of
cortisol i mean it's basically normal
over long-term long-term
so early when you start these diets and
it doesn't matter what diet children
it's kind of stressful
you know when you shift whether you're
going on a vegan diet or a plant-based
diet or a
carnivore diet or a keto diet you're
going to see an elevation in cortisol
we also know that cortisol can be
elevated for a number of different
reasons
uh there are enzymes there's something
called 11 beta
hydroxy stereo dehydrogenase i don't
know it's a mouthful
but it's expressed in the liver in the
in the fat tissue and
in the kidney the colon uh the
vasculature in the brain and different
versions of that
will either raise or lower cortisol and
fructose for one will
raise cortisol this is another thing you
know people talking about eating honey
to give you carbs but at the same times
we know fructose raises cortisol through
11 beta hydroxy steroid dehydrogenase
activity in the liver
so around the fat too so that
there's a reason it's going to be
cortisol can be up for certain reasons
that are good and
and up for certain reasons that are bad
just like cholesterol
it's just like any of these other
biomarkers we use so
there's a lot of extrapolation there and
i can tell you that i've seen
gosh i don't know how many labs on
people that have been a carnivore for
long periods of times and very very
often most of the time cortisol levels
are fine
interesting i found honey like i
generally in these facebook groups where
i
occasionally offer advice i i generally
tell people if they're going to
binge eat carbs because they're having
such
terrible cravings the way i dealt with
that and i actually when i switched over
to carnivore i just went from meat and
greens to meat and it was pretty easy
um but when i first cut out grains the
carb cravings were so terrible that i
ate honey
and my like inflammatory response to
honey was just almost nothing compared
to you know eating something like
grains so that's generally where i see
it come in
yeah i mean i think you know relative to
other carbohydrate-based options and
again i am not of the belief that
carbohydrates are necessarily inherently
bad for people
i think that's again this is you know
when i have people in there saying
vegetables are poison and carbs are
poison
i don't agree with that even though i
promote a meat-based diet which doesn't
include carbohydrates in general i mean
there's a little bit of carbohydrates
and eggs
a little bit in some dairy you know but
i mean generally i don't eat much in oil
carbohydrates but
i don't believe that they're always evil
for every single person i think
it depends on what it comes with you
know it's not the carbohydrate that's a
problem it's the
for some people it's select and for some
people let's see oxalate for some people
it's the you know the phytic acid or
whatever you know you just name it on
and on and on
uh and so that's where i think the
issues are and so honey doesn't have
fiber which for some you know
as crazy as it sounds fiber for many
people just doesn't
do well for their gut and for some
people excluding fiber so honey tends to
be pretty low in fiber
i'm not there probably a little bit in
there i haven't looked i can't remember
but i think it's pretty low in fiber
and you know generally probably pretty
well tolerated for a lot of people now
again it doesn't mean you need to be
eating
you know lots of it all the time every
day it's probably something you reserve
is a
rare occasional treat perhaps you know
and again there's people
as you know we have a lot of people that
deal with food addiction whether you
believe in them
believe in it or not there are people
out there that if they start like your
experience with the i believe in it you
start having a little bit and then all
of a sudden it's like
i just can't stop them it's going to
keep going and then it's like well i had
some yesterday and i didn't die i'm
going to have some tomorrow
and then pretty soon you know you're
you're three months into this and you've
gained 20 pounds and half your issues
have come back and then you're like crap
and then you're back to square one kind
of thing
yeah i i tried reintroducing honey to in
the summer and
i don't know i just cut everything out
like when i stopped feeling good i was
like ah nah i'm
i'm back to what i've been doing but um
i don't think it was
you know like you said it doesn't have
all the other things that
you know something like fruit might have
that might be provoking
an immune response perhaps yeah i mean i
you know i think from a from you think
about what what a
again going back to a sort of an
evolutionary sort of thought you know
you think about what humans had access
to
um i don't think vegetables would have
been high on the list of things people
would want to
want to eat because you know
particularly like the leaves and stems i
mean you're not gonna get much nutrition
out of that i mean it's gonna
most of it is very bitter tasting most
plants out there i mean you know i know
people are shocked to find this out but
if i
look in my backyard and it's full of
trees and leaves any of the leaves i
would eat out there would make me
profoundly sick if not some of them
might even kill me
so there's there's very few real reason
if you've got
you know particularly fatty meat maybe
some veg maybe some
some fruits in season that you would eat
much outside of that you know maybe
maybe you get a little tuber or mushroom
or a nut here and there but
i i i would see the vegetables would be
one of the last things
we would resort to as as a backup food
you know in dire situations and it's
only since we've been able to
massively cultiva cultivate and you know
modify these foods that they've
you know even entered the human diet
most vegetables are
some are only a you know a few decades
they're not two decades a few hundred
years old at most
and yeah and people wouldn't have also
spent the time getting used to the taste
like
i loved salad and i was a huge vegetable
eater
i was never vegetarian but i loved my
vegetables but
there's the initial process of getting
used to the bitter taste so that you
actually grow to like them
and i would assume that most of our
ancestors wouldn't have spent
you know a week getting used to
something better just
in order to enjoy it later they would
have tried it and been like nah
well you all yeah i mean if it didn't
make them sick and i think that's
it's something that you know there's not
much calories in it it was a point of
eating you know i mean
back then it wasn't you know social it
wasn't uh
you know it was it was to get calories
to get nutrients to fuel your body to
keep you moving and
salad just doesn't do it yeah okay
well we should wrap up um where can
people find you and
do you have any new projects in the
future yeah so
uh meet our x i'm there every day so
meterx.com i do i host a meeting every
single morning nine a.m seven days a
week 365 days a year for an hour
sometimes it's a it's a guest interview
and turns into a podcast but most of the
time it's just the members
asking questions and we just kind of
chat and learn stuff about
what we're doing and advancing the
knowledge so that's every single day i'm
there
um i have uh social media uh
i guess i should talk about parlor
parlay
maker sean 67 since i just kind of
relatively started that one and i guess
there's some concern about
censorship on these other platforms but
the traditional ones instagram
sean baker in 1967
s-h-a-w-n-b-a-k-e-r-1967
um twitter s bakermd i've got a youtube
channel
it's just sean baker um facebook i don't
really do much on facebook while i
started the world
carnivore try which is the biggest
carnivore
group in existence my knowledge it's
like 50
you know 51 000 or so members doing that
so those are the places where i've
often frequent uh you know booked the
carnivore diet
still out selling well a lot of people
have read that and i've really
found it to be a very practical way to
to utilize the diet and you know
it's it's accessible to most people from
the way i wrote it so
anyway that's that's where you can find
me okay and just to give anybody
listening an idea about meat rx
if i like sometimes people reach out and
ask me if i'm doing
the consultations or anything to get
questions answered medrx is a place you
could go that you can actually
get those questions answered so i
i've like been in just to browse around
and things and i would recommend
it if you're like feeling alone and need
a place to go to be able to speak to a
doctor and other people
it looks like a good community yeah
we've got meetings for
all different ilks i mean whether it's
women's groups whether it's diabetes
whether it's weight loss whether it's
you know fasting whether it's you know
there's like 20 or some 30 meetings a
week plus a daily meeting that i do
there's coaching for
i mean gosh 18 a coaching session which
is incredibly
cheap we're about to we're about to roll
out instant coaching so you can just
press a button on an app and get a coach
pop up right away so we've got
we've got a whole bunch of things going
on in the work and then again we're
gonna be collecting data
we've got recipes we've got uh resource
we have physicians supportive physicians
and if you want if you need a physician
we've got lists of
all kinds of meat suppliers ranchers
discounts
so it's and you know we've got 8 000
plus scientific articles on there as far
as hundreds and hundreds of
you know uh you know just uh
discussion pages on on different topics
so it's a it's a pretty
comprehensive place to go yeah cool very
cool well thank you
for coming on it was nice chatting with
you thanks mikayla for having me and
good luck to you and hopefully your
family's
doing well this you have a better we all
have a better year this year this twenty
years oh my god i hope so yeah
i hope so thanks sean all right thanks
i hope you enjoyed the episode i'm
switching my
release schedule to every sunday and
every wednesday from now on
so there won't be an episode this friday
it'll be on sunday and it'll be with
my dad and coleman hughes which is
amazing
it was super fun my dad hasn't released
a podcast with anyone other than me
in two years so this is a pretty big
deal so that's november 30th
this coming sunday and from now on
podcasts will be released
sunday and wednesday thank you enjoy
your week
you